وشكرا على طرح هذا الموضوع الذي اعتقد
بانه يستحق ان يكون وان يحظى بالنقاش في
هذه المرحله من تطور العالم العربي فيما
يتعلق فيما يرجع الى المقاله بطبيعه الحال
انا متابع الليبي بحكم الانتماء الى
المنطقه المغاربيه وايضا بحكم تتبعي الى
اثار
الربيع العربي على كثير من الدول بطبيعه
الحال ليبيا منذ 2011 وهي يعني تراوح
مكانها فيما يتعلق بالبحث عن حل
للوضع الحالي لانه مع الاسف العقيد معمر
القذافي لم ينشئ دوله بعد الانقلاب على
الملك ادريس سنوسي بل انشا حتى مؤسسه
الجيش التي كان يمكن ان تكون رابطا وجامعا
فكك مؤسسه الجيش وانشا ميديشيات يقودها
ابناؤه ومناصره ما لفت انتباهي وان العامل
الذي شكل موضوع وحده لانه التيارات التي
شاركت في ثوره 17 شباط 17 17 فبراير
الليبيه كانت من مشارب مختلفه امتيارات
سياسيه مختلفه هناك ليبراليين هناك
اليساريين هناك ايضا جزء من الاسلام
السياسي اذا كان هناك اختيارات متعدده لكن
لافت ان العامل الذي شكل وحده بكل هذه
التيارات المتناقضه كان هو العوده الى
عالم المملكه الليبيه فشكل علم المملكه
الليبيه بالوانه الثلاث التي تشير وترمز
الى مناطق الثلاث فزان وبرقه وطرابلس شكل
عامله واحده ومنطلقا لتوحيد الجهود في
مواجهه نظام العقيد معمل القذافي وبقايا
نظامه في اطار ثوره فبراير ايضا العوده
الى نشيد الاستقلال سنه 19 مع انشاء
المملكه السنوسيه الليبيه سنه 1951 اذا
بالعوده الى ثم ان التطورات التي عرفتها
ليبيا منذ 2011 لليوم
كثير من الاصوات التي ارتفعت اولا بعوده
النظام الملكي ايضا لتوحيد هذه المناطق
التي كانت تاريخيا دائما منقسمه وقد نجح
الملك ادريس نوسي في توحيدها في مرحله
سابقه وايضا هناك النقاش حول المرجعيه
والارضيه الدستوريه لبناء لكي يتم البناء
عليها في المستقبل وكانت من بين الوثائق
التي تم الاشاره اليها نبيل الفرقاء وهو
دستور المملكه الليبيه 1951 وهو بالمناسبه
كان دستورا متقدما بالنظر الى ما كان
سائدا في المنطقه في تلك الفتره اذا كان
هذا هو المنطلق وخاصه في المراحل
الانتقاليه كيف يمكن ان تكون العوامل
المشتركه وكيف ان يكون لثقل التاريخ عاملا
يؤسس لوحده وطنيه يمكن البناء عليها